へいへい
あああああ
皆さん
もしこの光景を目にしてしまったらどうしますか
散らかっているペットボトルを拾ってみますか
怒って
sns に投稿しますか
それともどうせ一人で頑張っても何も変わらないからといって諦めて
目をそらしますか
この写真は実は
私が2年ちょっと前に素敵な海を追いかけに入って沖縄に行った時に撮った写真です
そして私の今全力で取り組んでいる仕事のスタート時点でもありました
ある日歩いているとこのゴミだらけのピッチを発見してしまいました
衝撃的な光景でした
気候変動海洋ゴミ問題
このような言葉を聞くと
課題が壮大すぎてどこから手をつけたらいいのか分からないという方が多いと思います
私も
このゴミだらけのビーチを見て
私たち人間ってこの使いてペットボトルだったりとにかく便利を追求して環境犠牲に
マチ底まで行ってしまってるなーって
それがもある意味使いて文化のようなものになってしまってるなぁって
最初は正直すごく無料券に感じました
だってそれを変えようなんて思っても日本だけの場合でも日本の人口1億2700万人
が共通するこの文化を一人で変えようなんてウイでしょ
じゃあどうしたらいいのか
私はその時無力に感じながらも
でもなんか嫌なキャとにかくひどかったからそのときにできることは何なのかって考え
た時に友達にシェアしたり sns に投稿したりしてみました
すると
えー何かひどいけど私も実はここに行ったら
2体のとこ見たよって
メッセージが返ってきたり写真が送られてきたりしてなんか一緒にできないかねって
いうコメントももらって
そしてその周りと話しば話すほど南下したいよね
なんか一緒にできないかねってそういう仲間に私は実は囲まれたことに気付きました
ちょっと周りに聞いたぐらいでこれで家何かやりたいって言ってくれる仲間がいるので
あればもっと多いはずだしその多くの人たちが一緒になって行動すればもしかすると
それなりの影響力を及ぼすことができるかもしれない
そのコミュニティの力でこの使い捨て文化を書いていこうっていうミッションを掲げて
立ち上げたのがなイメージです
マイ水は無料で急性できる場所人々につなげているプラットフォームです
このアプリを中心に一般の人が公的水の外を投稿したりお店ビジネスにも登録して
もらったりして
今は世界各地に10万カ所以上の救世スポットがつながっているネットワークになり
ます
例えば日本人のカフェやレストランも登録されては
意外な例えば上ねーぞエラーの近くの暗さをって島国のリゾート地だったり
コスタリカのカフェドイツのコワーキングスペースそして想定外の牧場みたいなところ
も登録されています
マイ水は2019年去年の9月に論したばかりで私たちが目指す持続可能な未来って
まだ遠く感じます
しかもこのタイミングでロンチたのもあって
やっぱり大変な目にもあっています
私の春に外出自粛の要請された時にはすべてのプロジェクトがキャンセルとなったり
もう足もしまいかなって思ったことも何度もあります
でも
このミッションに向かってとにかく人を巻き込むということに必死に取り組んできたり
そのビジョンを発信し続けてきたことによって
世界的に有名なブランド企業そして日本国内外の自治体も一緒に取り組みたいって
じゃあに入ってもらったり
せねしてもインフルエンサーの方が拡散してくれたりするようになって
我々のアプローチも例えば環境車
国連国際デザイン賞にも認めていただいたりするようになりました
人を巻き込む
とにかく1巻き込もうという思いでやってきたんですけれどもこの14カ月はこれに
関して本当に学びの多い14ヶ月でした
で周りにもどうやってした巻き込んでのってよく聞かれるようにもなったので今日は
少しでも参考になればと思って
私はその経験を基に大切だとも3つのポイントをシェアさせて頂ければと思います
最初はポジティブなビジョンを共有することだと思います
課題の深刻さ規模を知るのはもちろん大切ですがどこに向かっていくのかっていうのを
共有することが大切だと思います
マイ水を立ち上げたときビジョンしかありませんでした
でもそのビジョンをなるべく魅力的に周りの人達に共有してみたらその未来なら一緒に
作り上げてきたいって
仲間なちーてきてチームが作れました
そのチームの力でミミズアプリのベータ版を作れたらそれをテストしてもらうように
テストパイド g ユーザ募集したところ48時間以内に100人のユーザがなつまり
ました
その人たちはアプリはまだ使えてないのに
ビジョンだけに共有してくれて集まりました
今でもマイ水に参加してくれている人たち
給水パートナー企業パートナーでもなぜ枚水に参加したかと聞くと
マイ水の世界観とビジョン肉共感できたからっていう言葉が返ってくることが多いです
やっぱりその問題の深刻さを知ると同時に一緒に作り上げていきたいよなビジョンを
共有することが大切だと思います
二つ目は
行動変容を可能にするわかりやすいツールです
マイ水に参加した理由を聞くと元もう一つ帰ってくるのが
今すぐにでもできることだったからという言葉です
マイボトルを持って
救世することは
誰にも出来ること
そしてお店も
手間もお金もほとんどかけずに参加することができる
ペットボトル自動販売権これだけ日本日本には
救世なんか広まらないよって散々言われてきました
でも実際ロンチてみたらこういうの待ってましたって声をわざわざ連絡してくれたり
今までは仕方なくペットボトル買ってしまってたけどこれがあると思うマイボートで
使えるし
すごい嬉しいってコメントもはだって
ペットボトルを減らしただけでは
世界中の環境問題解決されません
でもその最初に一方これらできるっていうのは知るのは大切だと思います
ポジティブなびぢゃんツールこの2つに加えて何が必要でしょうか
私はコミュニティが大切だと思います
なぜなら私もそうだったんですけれども
何か新しいことに取り組むときにはやっぱり人間って仲間が欲しいです
マイ水のコミュニティは小さなところから始まりました
とにかく巻き込みやすい友達同僚からでも sns を活用したり
クラウドファンディングキャンペーンを実施したりすると自然と横のつながりで
どんどん広まってきました
知らないうちにすごい楽しくなってその大企業の方だったり
インフルエンザの方も仲間になってくれてました
いま日本中世界中
一人じゃないって自信を持って環境問題に取り組んで仲間のコミュニティーになってい
ます
私はこのコミュニティは
その使い捨て文化を変えていく力があると思っています
今までは
この人々を巻き込むための3つのポイントをシェアさせていただきました
ポジティブなビジョンを持つこと分かりやすいツールと
コミュニティの大切さ
難しい
もうひとつお伝えしたいことがあります
今までこのように広まってきた活動はすべてそのある日この衝撃的な光景を見た時に
諦めずにとりあえずできることから始めたから始まりました
皆さんにも最初期も小さく感じてもできることはあると思います
そしてすでに出来てるって方は一緒により多くの人たちを巻き込むことができると思い
ます
皆さんも一緒にこのポジティブのビジョンに向かって
使い手文化を一緒に変えていくことに
取り組みませんか